John we have this question come in from
brian e kid on facebook what are the
best resources for keeping up to date
with or ahead of the trends and
distribution IE new platforms new models
the ones that are emerging is
significant the ones that are failing
and driving away etc so that's i wish i
had a one i wish i had one answer for
that because my intention at one point
with the book was to create a website
that would do precisely that that became
too much work and i still want to do
that and sherry candler and i talked
about doing a mat we talked about doing
a PMD site which would do that it's just
a matter of that has not happened yet so
um one of these days it will maybe so in
lieu of that i would say following Ted
you know Ted hope following sherry you
know following me um you know and trying
to think of who else you know us out
there you know film collaborative I
think the filmmaker magazine site has
you know distribution and marketing a
pretty active distribution and marketing
blog and they're kind of kind of they're
going to relaunch the site that will
have a ways to access a lot of
information in a more robust fashion so
I would say that indiewire as well but
the thing is is that what you want to do
is be able to kind of like you know
archive it in a way and look back on it
so you know so I would say that you know
those resources you know it's a lot but
I would just you know just set up your
blog reader to you know capture you know
and set up your twitter feed for you
know those people in those places and
you're probably going to be pretty okay
you know
you